so a common phrase in the video world is
eh we'll fix it in post meaning the shot
isn't quite perfect but we'll just fix
that stuff in post
production kind of like
this there you go we uh how about a
little bit of this
too there we go much better see it's not
that it's a lazy way of doing it but I
feel like a good filmmaker tries to get
as reliably good in camera as possible
instead of relying on
software and uh the will fix it and post
version of a smartphone is definitely
the Google pixel so many of the pixel's
best features are literally fixing it in
post right oh is your face blurry in
that picture you took fine face un blur
fix it and post oh what's that you
didn't quite get that angle right on
your photo magic editor fix it and post
oh was there a weird background audio in
that video you took easy we got audio
eraser fix it and post and many of these
strategies With a Little Help from AI
actually work and that's where the pixel
shines but there's also some things
about smartphones that you kind of just
can't really fix and post first things
first the design on the outside of these
phones looks I'd say familiar it looks
like the past few years of pixel which I
actually really like but I also do think
this one's a little bit better in a few
ways first of all the camera circles did
the uh iPhone Dynamic Island thing of
combining themselves into one big Circle
which I actually like with these new
bigger sensors here and then also the
pro pixels now have a completely flat
display so finally moving away from the
slightly curved edges from the past
years and a satin back in every color
which does a shockingly good job at
hiding fingerprints if your team no case
like I am aside from that though
everything else is right where you'd
expect it the one thing I want to see if
maybe they can fix now is the dust that
always accumulates like right under and
above the camera bar probably the only
way to get rid of that is to sort of
curve it like they did on the Oppo Find
X4 and X3 but I don't know if they'll
ever do that but the biggest Improvement
to the hardware though is definitely up
front honestly to the point where I feel
like these new screens sort of tie the
phone together in a way that they are up
at the level of any other flagship phone
so the smaller pixel 8 now has a 6.2 in
1080P OLED display slightly smaller than
last year and that display is surrounded
Now by perfectly thin even bezels all
the way around no more tiny chin like
previous years and it's now bumped up to
120 HZ display that gets up to a new
maximum 2,000 nits of brightness which
is incredible it's super bright they're
naming it the actua display because they
feel the need to name everything but I
love how it's visible all the time auto
brightness has also been behaving this
time around which is great uh it's not
ltpo though so you'll still probably
want to turn off the o on display to
save a bit of battery but then the pixel
8 Pro has a new 6.7 in display it is
ltpo it's closer to 1440p and it maxes
out at 2400 nits Max brightness this one
is legitimately up there with the
brightest displays I've ever seen on a
smartphone in person and I definitely
did not expect that to come from a pixel
they're naming this the super actua
display so the result is a hardware
package on the outside of the phone that
honestly feels like you can put it right
up alongside any flagships from xiaomi
Samsung or anyone else you name it just
from the way it's built the way it feels
the metal rails the satin back the
clickiness of the buttons the super
bright display the even bezels
everything about it just this is a a
rare W for Pixel hardware and then two
other small things about this display
though one it's still just a single
front-facing camera at the top but
Google has found a way with software to
get more information out of this camera
in order to be able to use it for secure
unlock for things like banking apps and
logging into things so basically instead
of adding more Hardware up front like an
infrared camera or a DOT projector or
radar if you remember that they just fix
it and post with software magic and it's
convenient but then number two the
fingerprint reader has not improved so
remember we were talking about this in
the past few years of pixels all the
best the highest end flagships feels
like they all have that super fast
ultrasonic fingerprint reader this one
is still Optical and still just a little
bit just a beat slower than the high end
ones it's not horrible but you can tell
it's not as fast or as consistently
accurate with like rain on your phone as
something like a Samsung phone it's also
not any bigger either but hey as long as
we're talking about the pixel we might
as well just get right into talking
about the camera because this is where
you're going to see the fix it and post
push to its absolute maximum more than
any other phone so the new camera
sensors across the board they do plenty
of heavy lifting of course it's a big 50
megapixel primary sensor shared across
both the 8 and the 8 Pro f1.7 ois and
pixel photos they look good they're
sharp there's tons of dynamic range as
expected autofocus is really fast and it
can get a pretty shallow depth of field
with close-up subjects which is nice but
really most of what you're looking at
when you look at a pixel photo or video
is software so the multiple exposures
Blended together into a single HDR shot
the Strategic relighting of recognized
faces I also I do feel like there's a
little extra noise reduction this year
so sometimes details get kind of waterc
colory but at least there's enough
resolution that it doesn't look terrible
when zoomed out and I've also found
there is definitely a tendency to over
HDR some images sometimes and when it
comes to Features well oh my god there
are so many now you probably already
know about Magic Eraser look oh what's
that you've taken a photo and someone's
in the background you want to get rid of
them boom Magic Eraser fix it and post
oh what's that you have a photo where
someone's moving a little too fast or
the hands were shaky and the face is
kind of blurry well there's a feature
called face unblur literally fix it and
post and then even this new one called
best take people with kids are going to
love this one basically you know how you
anytime you take a group photo where
there's like five or six people on the
photo you just you just blast you just
take a bunch of pictures and inevitably
one person's face they're either
blinking or sneezing or something it's
never perfect but this feature will let
you go into that group shot and this is
for any group shot you've ever taken in
your Google photos Library by the way
not just shot on the pixel and it
automatically recognizes the burst of
photos and lets you pick the best face
from the whole burst on each person
in the photo with surprisingly
impressive accuracy you will genuinely
never have that one person with their
eyes closed or looking the wrong way in
a group photo ever again I guess that
makes your holiday cards that much
easier but also even in videos you know
I've taken a lot of videos on the pixel
8 and 8 Pro there's a lot of processing
happening I do think pixel video is
improved over last year it's less noisy
in the shadows and there's some nice
shallow depth of field with quick
autofocus um I shot almost the entire
Corvette Z6 autofocus video on the pixel
8 Pro and I think it looks really good
but also in a lot of the shots of my
face there's this artificial brightening
processing like you can see it in my
footage before I start talking when it
lands on my face how it just brightens
up my face and adds this contrast and
and just throughout the footage there is
a good amount of processed sharpening
going on also the audio eraser video
feature is all right I would say again
you can only fix so much in post but
basically they show this feature where
if you're taking videos and there's some
background noise you can go into the
editor and separate out like the layers
of different sounds so there's this
really cool UI that they've built in
that is super impressive you go into
edit audio and audio eraser it analyzes
the video and then lets you drag up or
down levels of different sounds that's
identified so nature and voices and
background sounds and wind you know
depends on what video you took it does
okay with small stuff but like I don't
know it's super impressive at a low
level but then it can't really save the
most disruptive wind around our studio
or the exhaust sound of a 5 and 1 half
lit naturally aspirated V8 like it's not
it's not magic about this in the main
channel in the remat Nea video that car
is electric and basically has multile
personalities and this one kind of does
in the same way You' probably heard the
other cliche of I will say shout out to
the colors though hly the color in Pixel
video is really good if you told me I
could only take pictures by taking
stills from video of any smartphone I
think I would pick the pixel 8 Pro just
the footage looks so good now Google
here's the thing about being so good at
software visibly is it becomes way more
obvious when you're suddenly not able to
pull off a software trick on the non-pr
phone that you are able to pull off on
the pro phone even though they're the
same computer like
the the good thing that you did was put
the same exact chip the tensor G3 with
the same image signal processor and the
same primary camera and the same selfie
camera in the Pro and the non-pro phones
so this sort of artificial separation
between the pro and the non-pro with
like software
locking it was obvious when Apple did it
and it's even more obvious when Google
does it so if you open up the camera and
switch over to Pro controls that's only
available on the pro phone
now that's funny of course you can argue
the nonpr phone doesn't need Pro
controls but it's clearly capable of
them even if you bury them in settings
it's the same computer they also both
have a 50 megapixel sensor but because
it's locked under the pro mode you can
only take 50 megapixel shots on the pro
phone the non-pr phone is always binning
theoretically that's going to be one of
the things that you'll have to pay the
$300 extra dollar to get up to the Pro
phone for but also someone's already
ported it to the pixel 6 so like come on
Google you ain't sck there's even a blog
post about some other features that are
coming to the pixel they have this thing
called Zoom enhance that's basically a
generative fill version of super res
Zoom that's coming later this year only
to pixel 8 Pro for some reason and
especially improved Magic Eraser version
that uses generative fill on the 8 Pro
and only the 8 Pro it's ridiculous it's
obvious what's being done out here it's
on a nightly basis I hope the world can
see now what's really going on out here
cuz it's getting ridiculous it's really
ridiculous okay last camera thing magic
editor
is it's wild it's one of the wildest
Things they've ever made it is available
on both phones and it it definitely goes
beyond fixing it in post so you open up
a photo you hit edit and then at the
bottom left corner there's this
wonderful colorful rainbow magic editor
button just tempting you to press it
from here the editor UI is basically
saying all right go ahead and select
something with your hands
and then we can change it we can do
whatever you want to it select an object
and you can remove it move it around
resize it select a person we can move
them up or down or hit the bottom middle
button to switch the whole scene to
Golden hour or replace the entire sky in
your photo and then once you submit the
edit it takes a few seconds to process
and then kind of like Dolly it gives you
four options of this edit to pick
whichever version is the most convincing
they're not you know professional
photographer level edits meaning you can
zoom in and pixel Peep and find some
edges sometimes that look weird here or
there I also did try the exact same
generative fill example that they showed
in their commercials of this kid on a
park bench where it oppressively fills
in the missing balloons when I do it it
kind of tries to do that but definitely
doesn't do it nearly as well but the
truth is zoomed all the way out these
are decently convincing edits to regular
people and you can just do it with any
photo in your library so it really just
feels like without knowing how to use
Photoshop or any of these image
generation AI tools the pixel magic
editor basically what it did is just it
lowered the barrier to entry to just lie
I guess now every once in a while I did
get a pop-up box over my edit attempt
that said uh it's unable to show results
because it might violate our gen AI
terms but I was never able to find like
exactly why or any Trend in this it
seemed to come up more often when I
tried to edit a picture of person but
then it would totally let me just select
a watermark in a photo and effortlessly
delete that which is probably going to
be concern for some photographers so
yeah I would just say I'm probably going
to end up making an entire separate
video just about this tool CU it's
fascinating and and what it brings into
the world is wild uh but I don't know
what is a photo but you know what you
can't fix and post though battery life
you can't AI your way out of a huge 2400
nit screen burning through battery
you're you're just going to need the
hardware you're going to need a big
battery you're going to need an
efficient chip for this one and I'm
happy to report that I have had really
good battery life on the pixels and this
is especially on the 8 Pro so I've
gotten 6 to 8 hours of screen on time
regularly uh standby time has been
decent my only real question at this
point is and I only ask this because of
the history we've seen with the pixel
how long will the battery life be this
good because you know it could be great
for a few months and then start to fade
like previous pi pix or maybe it'll be
great for years the whole time you own
the phone only time will tell at the end
of the day though the pixel is still
great at what it's always been great at
which is being smart like there are so
many features from call screening to
Google Assistant everywhere Google stock
apps getting so good and the more I use
the pixel as my daily phone as I have
for so long the more I just kind of get
used to this stuff and the harder it is
to live without it on another phone
Android 14 has already breathed life
into older pixels already literally my
biggest primary bug is clicking Twitter
notifications for some reason just take
an extra beat and a half to open kind of
weird one of the new features on this
one is when you're in any web page in
Chrome you can pull up Google assistant
and just ask it for a summary of the
entire web page you're reading and
Google Assistant with this new AI
features reads your screen and generates
a summary of three or four bullet points
that are typically pretty good now I
went and try this with a few other apps
but I basically always got an error
saying this app doesn't support
summaries so it looks like the app
developers are going to have to opt in
to have their apps scraped by the
summaries which I kind of suspect a lot
of them are not going to do that even
Google's own news app doesn't support it
so this basically is is just a chrome
thing and then after the summary it
gives you a few cards to ask follow-up
questions about the subject and just
keep Googling more stuff but then just
this phone gets a lot of the little
stuff right too just the little things
that make it feel like a flagship the
haptics are excellent like it's got some
of the highest quality phone calls I've
ever heard on a phone stuff like that
overall when you put fit and finish and
Hardware up alongside software
experience and I think these new screens
especially it feels like this this is
finally the generation of pixel that is
right alongside the other flagships of
the smartphone world and it gets
supported like a flagship too 7 years of
software updates 7 years of feature drop
updates 7 years of security updates 7
years of spare parts available and it'll
do so for the new starting price of $700
$ and I think it's worth it I honestly I
think this is worth the new price tag I
think everything they've done from the
120 HZ and the brighter screen across
the board this is a phone that I would
have no problem recommending now is the
$300 extra dollars for the pro worth it
that one's going to be tough and again
it's because Google did such a good job
with feature parody Same chip same
primary camera between these so it's
going to come down to the couple of
small differences between them do you
want that telephoto camera and the
bigger screen bigger battery bigger
phone the temperature sensor I don't
know that this is harder to recommend
the pro for most people but the pixel8
this is a good phone so that's basically
it thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
[Music]
peace